[Music]
it's the third season of new growth yeah
such a success it seems like
increasingly as the writers get used to
you you get used to them
they they throw more stuff at you that
looks like it'd be a lot of fun like
they they they you you came in one day
and they said we want you to do an elvis
impression we want you to dress up as
elvis and be elvis presley they just
started throwing impressions at me kind
of
maybe just as a joke at first and then
started
throwing weirder and weirder and weirder
ones and then elvis was was one of my
favorites and you went all out for this
i think we have a picture of you
uh
yeah
i don't have a close-up but you got
[Applause]
you've
yeah
you've got the i mean the costumes one
thing but you've got the trademark
you've got the snarl well i got really
into it uh the whole weekend before we
started shooting that show um
i just watched elvis movies and um and
kind of picked up things elvis said like
hey mama you know kind of that's right
yeah yeah so then i was like it was all
really built around hey mama it was my
[Laughter]
my elbow you build up from hey mama hey
there
what song did you do i did it in the
ghetto i love that song and um
uh burn in love
which is one of the great ones classic i
mean there's so many great ones so those
are the ones i listen almost exclusively
to the elvis channel i'm serious yeah
and when i'm driving home i mean i get
recognized people drive by and i'm just
freaking out
in the car your hair went right back
hey
that was amazing yeah
we just found my talent